hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most impressive bullet games i have ever
seen
it's from the last leeches titled arena
and it features uh world champion magnus
carlson and daniel naraditsky
now uh it's uh it's quite a game i'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it but before we
check out the actual game i would just
like to bring your attention
uh to the new and improved frame here as
you can see
uh it's um uh there i'm having trouble
uh showing it
uh it's uh it's a gift from a subscriber
daniel rossini he sent this to me and
it's basically the exact same as my old
one only this one is a bit more polished
so sort of as in
uh high definition uh the when i was
still deciding on the looks of my
channel i didn't know what kind of a
frame to use and there weren't all that
many you could choose from online so i
chose this one it's basically a frame
from hearthstone
and now i don't know if they improved it
or what but
now he he he sent me this improved
version so now it's not blurry but it's
actually
quite quite nice so thank you for that
uh now i i do imagine the frame is much
more enjoyable for everyone
uh not to the contents of the frame of
course but the frame itself
uh so that being said uh let's check out
this game so magnus with the white
pieces opens with e4
and here we have a very very interesting
uh opening we have e5 and now
d4 going for the for the center game we
have e
cap person b4 and magnus captures with
the queen
you don't have to recapture the pawn
there are many ways to treat this
position you could play c3 give more
pawns then play
some lego bishop c4 knight f3 but magnus
grabs the pawn right away so queen
captures on d4
knight to c6 attacking the queen and the
queen to c
for now uh and not quite uh maybe an odd
square for the queen but not really as
this is uh
amongst the uh engine's top
recommendations so here knight to f6
attacking this pawn one more time and
knight to c3 magnus defends it we have
bishop to b4 now pinning the defender
of this uh now there's even the threat
of just capturing and if white
doesn't want to mess up his pawn
structure he's going to have to capture
with the queen remove the defender of
the e4 pawn and so on
so here bishop to d2 now getting uh
the the bishop to help out with the
defense and now uh
knight goes back uh sorry and here both
players castle so castles castles
magnus goes for the queen side castle he
doesn't want to be behind in development
and rook to e8 putting more pressure on
the e4 pawn with f3 magnus defends it
and now this is a pretty standard setup
magnus has this e4 f3
and he's ready to push h4 g4 g5 h5 and
so on and try to checkmate the black
king
and black will of course do the same on
the queen side as we do have castles on
opposite sides of the board so here
d6 preparing bishop to e6 to start
harassing the white queen
and g4 magnus starts the the pawn storm
on the king side with bishop to e6
attacking the queen
and queen back to e2 we have knight to
d4 now again attacking the queen
and of course making room for those
pawns to start being pushed forward with
queen to f2
now attacking the knight and now c5
defending this knight
and magnus plays a3 and more often than
not when you have
a situation like this when there's
castles on opposite sides
uh you will not retreat you will rather
play queen to a5
and offer this will offer this bishop
and you don't really want to capture
this if you capture this for example a
captures on b4
queen to a1 check and that's just
terrible knight goes to b1 for example
bishop a2 and that's a game over there
there's no defending this
so instead after this um uh queen the a5
magnus has to make a decision does he go
for a counter attack or does he go
uh into a defensive idea and here i have
to remind you this is a bullet game so
both players only have one minute on the
clock no increment
and uh here it's very interesting the
the engine's top recommendation is g5
but this only yields a draw for white
and it's pretty much a forced draw
for example bishop captures and now if
you don't capture a bishop you could
play g
captures on f6 grab the piece and now
bishop captures on b2 and here
black has at least a draw you you have
to check and then if okay
if white moves then black even wins with
knight captures on c2
uh but here if king c1 we will basically
have a repetition of moves and it's a
draw
uh so magnus instead decided that he
would not go for
g5 he played knights to b1 and
interestingly
up to this point both players only spend
some 10 seconds on their clocks
so here bishop captures on d2 with check
magnus grabs back with the queen he
offers a queen trade and narudicki goes
back
queen to b6 uh he avoids the queen trade
as
he did spend a few seconds there so he
doesn't want to go
go for an end game against magnus here
and here magnus continues pushing
g5 uh we have knight to d7 and now
f4 and the things are already looking
very scary for black f5 is coming then
your entire kingside might might crumble
and the fact of the matter is that this
position is bad for white it's straight
out winning for black in fact so feel
free to pause the video here
and win the game for naraditsuki while i
give you a couple of seconds
and yes it's only move 16.
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
unspottable idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to b3 and this is just a
beautiful move
it's uh holding down on this c2 pawn and
there's no way to defend it and of
course you cannot capture the bishop if
you capture the bishop just knight
captures and this is a
game over you you lose the queen uh it's
check and
after the key moves you're going to just
pick up the queen on d2 so that's one
option the other option is to
maybe move the pawn you could play
something like c3 but then you just give
up the rook on d1
that's also losing so here magnus tried
the only thing he could after bishop to
b3 he played bishop to d3
now guarding the pawn but there's a
problem here
we have c4 now attacking the bishop here
and
this is what magnus was hoping for
because now after bishop captures he
opens up the attack towards the knight
here
but uh of course uh here comes rook 8
the c8 and now the position is just
just terrible because if you capture the
bishop now you get knight captures here
and this is
checkmate the pawn cannot capture due to
the rook being on c8
so this is obviously not possible so
magnus instead goes queen captures on d4
offers a queen trade now but now comes
rook
captures on c4 beautiful as it attacks
the queen
offers a queen but if you try and trade
queens here then the rook captures on c2
is checkmated this is just insane so
after rook captures on c4
magnus went back rook queen to d3 now
he's saying okay you capture with the
rook i'm gonna give up the queen for
your rook and bishop
but here narudinski has a a beautiful
beautiful finishing move so
i'm not going to ask you to pause the
video because this is actually in the
thumbnail
but yes here in our disc he played
quinta e3
with check he offers his queen and of
course the queen cannot be captured
because the queen captures
rook captures and c2 is again checkmate
so here
magnus had to play something he blocked
with rook to d2
but now again how do you bring uh more
pieces into the attack well you don't
have to all the pieces are
already here here narudisky played rook
captures on c2
and it was in this position on move 21
that magnus carlsen resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the king cannot capture the rook is
pinned the
the rook cannot capture so basically
your only options are king to d1 but
that just runs into this double check
from the rook and the bishop you have to
go back and then
bishop to d1 is again checkmate because
now it's check from the rook
and the queen this is beautiful uh and
if you don't uh
capture if you don't move the king you
could also capture with the queen
but then it's pretty pointless bishop
captures on c2 and the white has
zero compensation for the for the
sacrificed material if for example
captures queen captures with
check you're going to pick up the rook
on h1 as well it's uh completely winning
and the interesting thing about this
game is not only did it take uh narudic
at 21 moves to defeat magnus but it also
took him only 26 seconds so
that's uh that's just unimaginable if
if you told someone like 30 years ago
that someone could defeat the world
champion in all time formats
probably in blitz probably in bullet as
well if such a thing existed the world
bullet championship
that you could defeat him in any format
in 26 seconds that'd be
you know people would tell you you know
you should you know
get treated or something uh but yes
narutitsky crushed him
with this with this beautiful miniature
in only 26 seconds and
21 moves that's that's incredible
uh so that's basically it that's what i
want to show you a lot of you guys
suggested it and
i'm glad you did because when i saw it i
was like wow and
of course i can't follow absolutely
everything that's happening in the chess
world so it's very important that you
guys use use hashtag suggestions uh
and uh you know uh bring such games to
my attention using the comment section
below
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
oliver
uh nova roger stone mohamed risky and
the david david kimura for your
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day